الجمهورية القمعية تسحق
الانحدار بوحشية لا تعرف
حدوداً مدن كردية مثل هذه
تحمل وطأة قمع لا يرحم
لم يترك مكاناً آمناً مع
مطاردة قوات الأمن
للجرحى الآن لا يذهب الجرحى إلى المستشفيات
لأنهم إذا ذهبوا إلى هناك  سيقوم رجال شرطة بملابس مدنية
باعتقالهم حتى في معظم
الصيدليات ، حيث لا يمكنهم الذهاب
للعلاج لأنه سيتم
التعرف عليهم على الفور ويؤدي في النهاية إلى
اعتقالهم لهذا السبب لا
يتم علاج الأشخاص من جروحهم ،
فهذه ساق صبي يبلغ من العمر 14 عامًا
يتخللها  ما يبدو أنه جروح خرطوش
المتظاهرين في بلدته يعرفون أفضل من
الذهاب إلى المستشفى ، قصة تكررت
مرارًا وتكرارًا في جميع أنحاء البلاد ،
أخبر أطباء متظاهرون في مجموعة لحقوق الإنسان أن
مستشفيات سي إن إن تحولت إلى فخ
خطير للغاية بالنسبة للمتظاهرين طبيب
داخل إيران  الذي لا يريد أن يتم
الكشف عن هويته حفاظًا على سلامته ، تحدث إلينا من
خلال صوت المترجم
الذي يأتون إليه في الغالب  dercover ولكن في معظم
الأحيان يمكن التعرف عليهم من خلال بعض
العلامات التي يأتون إليها ويسألون عن
مرضى جدد إذا كانوا يريدون استخدام الهواتف ،
يتعين علينا الرد عليهم في معظم الأوقات
نستخدم أسماء مزيفة أو مكالمات وهمية
للمتظاهرين لمساعدتهم حتى يتمكنوا من
ذلك.  لا يتم التعرف عليه من خلال النوايا ، فإن
قوات
الأمن تتعقب عند
تحديد الأشخاص من خلال
الإصابات المروعة التي يتسببون فيها
بالمتظاهرين ، ولا يقتصر الأمر على أن
المتظاهرين في المستشفيات يقولون إن سيارات الإسعاف
تُستخدم لاحتجاز الأشخاص
في هذا الفيديو ، حيث يهاجم الناس سيارة إسعاف
بداخلها قوات الأمن.  يقول الراوي
إن المتظاهرين ينقذون فتاة لا
يعرفون من يمكنهم الوثوق به. يلجأ
المتظاهرون اليائسون الآن إلى
طبيب إيراني أمريكي في نيويورك للحصول
على مشورة طبية حاسمة عبر
Instagram الصور التي سيرسلونها لي ، هل
تعرف أنها أساسية كما تعرف الكسور و
عندما يهربون من
الشرطة مقابل الضرب الوحشي
، أرسل لي الناس
كسورًا في الجمجمة يحاولون تجربتها  ng للتعامل مع
ذلك في منزلهم الكريات المتعددة في
جميع أنحاء أجسامهم ،
يخشى الكثير منهم كما تعلمون قضاء السنوات
العشر القادمة من حياتي في السجن أو مجرد
دع هذا يعرف أن عظم الفخذ المكسور
يشفي من تلقاء نفسه الدكتور K كما هو  يُعرف
بالاعتماد على شبكة صغيرة من الأطباء تحت الأرض ،
وهو يثق في أن الكثير من هذا
يحدث
كما تعلمون في المناطق السرية التي تعرفها
مثل المناطق المخفية من قبل الأطباء الذين
يريدون أن يظلوا أطباء مجهولين يساعدون
المتظاهرين وقد تم اعتقالهم
ولكن هذا لا يتوقف  أولئك الذين يضعون
الواجب فوق الذات
كطبيب أرى أن هذا واجب لإنقاذ
الناس في أي مكان ثم المستشفى ليس
آمنًا أحاول مساعدة الناس في الشارع
بغض النظر عن المكان الذي
لا ينبغي أن يموت فيه ريس بسبب البحث عن
الحرية
[تصفيق]
وهارون سألنا الحكومة الإيرانية
عن الاعتقال الواضح
للمتظاهرين في المستشفيات والعيادات لكن
الحكومة الإيرانية لم
تستجب لطلبنا للتعليق على هذا آرون كما
أسمع من إيراني  الأمريكيون الذين
يتواصل معهم المزيد والمزيد من المتظاهرين ويطلبون مساعدتهم
لربطهم بالأطباء في الولايات المتحدة ،
إنه وضع يائس حقًا